and welcome to the podcast
this is hans kim here
um doing a podcast
so
this is just a good time overall
we're all having fun
and we are
relaxing and waiting for things to pop
off
hopefully
this is all working
yesterday i was very sad because
i thought i had been forgotten
um
by
my mentors and my
overlords but it turns out
i had actually been forgotten by my
mentors and overlords
but then i was remembered in a very
quick
fashion
it's always called flail impropriety
whatever
the good thing is it's getting out there
um what's up hans says robert ray
what's up robert ray says hans
um
and uh i got the call last night at 8 10
p.m
from
the man himself joe rogan and then i
took a little trip downtown
and did a little seti pooh and one of
the best probably the best comedy show
in the world happening right now
at the
vulcan um thanks for loving to see me on
kill tony robert ray
and uh performed for a sold out crowd
oh i'm always so nervous before i do it
it's such a nerve-wracking situation
because they have such high expectations
because comedy they're used to seeing
comedy being so awesome they're used to
joe rogan level of authenticity and
talent so it's just
one of the most nerve-wracking crowds to
perform in photo because they're always
judging you they're like
i don't know if this is the best of the
best of the best
luckily tim dillon was there to pick up
the slack that i might have produced but
i probably didn't because otherwise
uh why would joe rogan want me so you
know i have faith in joe rogan
and if he has faith in me then uh
whatever
[Music]
tony i guess
i mean i don't want to make it a big
deal but
yeah i mean i was super super sad
yesterday
and i streamed it live
uh norm's ghost says hopefully this
isn't offensive but do those eyes
provided the same views that mine do
hopefully they provided a view that is
uh better at detecting grammatical
errors
than uh you do
but uh i don't know how would i know
how would i know what kind of view my
eyes provide compared to what views your
eyes provide
a interesting question that you ask that
might be a curiosity inducing to you but
is actually
impossible to answer and also uh sort of
a dead end conversationally
so maybe have like a little bit more
um
you know like
awareness and forethought into
like asking questions that might be at
the tip of your tongue but might not be
the best for uh continuing a
conversation with an asian
just assume that
my eyes
have provided a view
that
[Music]
that is
a
view that looks like the type of view
that these eyes would produce if your
eyes look like this i'm a human just as
yourself i know it's very difficult for
some of you to have empathy and
see things from other people's eyes or
perspectives but you know give it a shot
and don't just rely on your
conversational partner to
make it easy to empathize with them but
uh you know work on your empathizing
muscle and
see how far you get
how do you come up with a minute per
week
um
i have a backlog right now of jokes um
that i'm dipping into uh
and then i'm always writing
i could do a minute of new stuff every
week if i wanted to but
it's sort of like
i don't want a bomb
so i do some jokes that i know work i
try to sprinkle in some new stuff but i
have so many old jokes
um and i hope it never runs out i'm
always surprised i'm like oh yeah i
remember that joke i did come up with a
new joke by looking through my notes
that i took during the pandemic that's
how i came up with the child molester
joke like why would you molest a child
they're the most time to come take
revenge on you not avenge you everyone
is so mad that i said avenge you
what's my process is i write 2 000 words
every day
into my little bluetooth keyboard and
into my phone
um
and then it goes right into the keyboard
and i write 2000 words i do a word check
a word count on my google docs
i make it black
or whatever
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
[Music]
i
i write 2000 words and that gets me in
the process of writing down my thoughts
and it teaches me how to write and then
for the rest of the day i have had that
practice of writing down my thoughts so
if i have a thought it's easier to write
down a thought because i've practiced
writing down thoughts
and
[ __ ] down thoughts
um i would love to
have sex with thoughts
um good to hear you got the call last
night all that down and disappoint me
felt not needed
well you know it's how i was feeling
it's i don't have emotions for a purpose
i just have emotions as a result of what
i'm going through but uh yeah i mean i
shouldn't uh be so down on myself and i
should try to pick myself up and be a
happy happy boy because tonight i'm
going to open up for joe rogan and this
whole weekend i'm going to open up for
joe rogan and tomorrow thursday night
i'm going to go to a little town called
houston texas and do the secret show
headlining a set there
um
and so you know it's just [ __ ]
awesome if you're in houston please come
down and visit and buy a ticket i get a
percentage of that so are you worried
about the omarion
yeah i mean maybe he's like usher or uh
jason derulo maybe he'll punch me if i
call him usher
i'm worried about omarion i'm worried
that he's a
r b singer that hasn't put out a hit in
recent years i'm worried about his
career i'm worried about his children's
future
i'm really worried about omarion
um you know i hope omarion can make a
quick recovery
and i hope that he doesn't lose his
sense of taste because his taste is very
good at whatever
are you worried about the omarion i mean
cases are sky high in america right now
um it's very disturbing and very uh
unnecessary and worrying but you know
what are you going to do we've already
established that we're going to do
literally nothing
against the coronavirus masks no stay
inside no vaccine no
we're just gonna get it uh there's
literally nothing we will do to stop
getting it
anything that is remotely
helpful against
the coronavirus we've already decided
it's not in our wheelhouse we're just
gonna freedom our way out of this
pandemic and you know
i hope it works
because you know the virus just has to
decide like okay i'm bored now let's
just be a localized phenomenon like the
[ __ ]
like kiss or like uh you know the beach
boys we just got to hope it plays itself
out and goes away on its own because
we're totally at the mercy of this virus
that doesn't even have a brain
to uh for the future of the only
sentient species that we know on earth
so yeah hopefully it decides to
have mercy on us and just quietly
we'll go away into the night
but honestly it's not up to us anymore
it's up to the virus since we've uh
displayed that our ability to think long
term and consciously is uh
not as up to the challenge as a virus
a virus has a better long-term strategy
than we do i mean we have a pretty good
civilization going it's just uh
worrisome that
we're not willing to do anything about
it
a disease even though we have all the
tools at our disposal we just have to
stop shopping for a bit but we really
love shopping
how can you get us to stop shopping that
is an american right
do you test all the minutes or try them
for the first time on kill tony i try
not to try them out for the first time
on kill tony i've done it once
with the kyle writtenhouse jokes
but that [ __ ] is on there forever and i
want that to be like a repository of all
my best [ __ ]
um but yeah i mean who knows
uh
i i would
put that minute on kill tony higher than
some of my shows that i do a lot for
most of the shows that i do
um
it's just um
you know it's just crazy because
it's out there forever and i want my
legacy on kill tony to be a positive one
and i want to just kill with the minutes
and i want to do really well so i just
try to make the minutes the best you can
can you open your eyes when you talk to
us can you open eyes when you talk to us
yeah i can open eyes when i talk to you
but they won't be my eyes it'll be
someone else's eyes
the funny thing is
is that when i'm wearing glasses my eyes
look more open for some reason
i think it's like a check of the lens
that it projects onto whatever or
something
okay now i can read the chat and also
look like my eyes are open
um
thoughts on pat and oswald being a bad
friend to mr sheppell
uh chappelle
um i mean i um i think that chappelle's
uh talked about transgender people a lot
and i think it's um
i think it's
it's uh
i i wouldn't have made that choice i
mean who gives a [ __ ] what i would have
done
but uh yeah i mean i think it's
he he's like found a little itch in our
society that we are very sensitive about
and then he keeps picking at it
um
and i don't know i uh
i don't know he's he seems pretty dead
set on
talking about transgender stuff
and then patent oswalt responding to the
criticism
um of him taking a picture with dave
chappelle and being like i support
transgender rights i don't know what
exactly he said but i uh
i think that he's
pat oswalt shouldn't have like
responded back to the mob
i mean
dave chappelle you might not agree with
him about what he said about transgender
people
but
i think that
you uh you can admire someone and be
friends with someone even if they're
transphobic
um
and i think that you should be friends
with people instead of uh you know
shunning them
for having problematic views uh because
you can work better within the system
maybe we should just have like a
a shunning process where anyone who has
problematic views we treat like [ __ ] but
that's not how humans work humans
have lots of different views on lots of
different things and we get along with
each other
even if we don't agree with them and
the thing about humans is that we're not
opinion gathering machines we are we
have more value than
our stances and just because you're
wrong on a stance doesn't mean that
um
that you should not have friendship or
be a part of society
um and i think that chapel does have a
large large influence
so he should uh he has more of a
responsibility but i don't think that we
should um
emotionally hurt him or socially
ostracize him
i think that just a conversation and a
back and forth is uh
is what we should do
i didn't have a slip and fall
um
[Music]
if you people pump more dollars will you
put more air into the neck pillow sure
hans what the heck is that on your neck
it's a cervical traction device that
prevents
my discs from
uh squishing into each other and
the [ __ ] juices in my disk or
whatever
uh
this neck pillow is uh to
uh you know this is how coronavirus
spread someone put in a neck pillow and
then they just release the valve on
americans
and
italians in bergamo
uh
yeah i don't know why pat and oswalt
posted such a long thing
um i mean you shouldn't have to explain
why you took a picture with people
um
would you marry a white woman hans or
strictly korean or maybe just asian for
marriage i would rather i would marry a
white woman before i married an asian
that's not korean because that's just
like
so weird to see an asian face and they
don't speak korean or love kpop or eat
taki
like what
like you're so close to human but you
don't uh
you don't watch kdramas it's like are
you even one of us it's just so
confusing no i'm obviously kidding i
love japanese women i watch a lot of
their pornography
i love chinese women if they made good
pornography i would watch it
um i really don't give a [ __ ] about
people's races um but you have to be hot
if hot is a race then that is i'm a
racist
um yeah but every every race has hot
women in it so i'm totally down for
a hot girl like if a hot girl wanted to
marry me and she was chinese i'd be like
actually i'm looking for a korean hot
girl next
nice strike ccp
um
china
chinese gf agrees
uh yeah i mean why are you like looking
for a certain type of love from a
certain race
um
would you marry a black woman yes um
[Music]
zendaya is black i think
zendaya uh who else is black
a lot of hot black girls you got the
[ __ ] up from scrunch sleeping in his
van
i wish
no kettlebell yet
i should get one where do you think the
best open mic to go to in austin is to
watch young comedians outside kill tony
um
creek in the cave is always good and
depressing um
lucky duck is uh no i want to go to
lucky duck it's just too chaotic it's
outside there's picnic tables people are
just talking it's a bunch of cool kids
bunch of yuppies yupping me yuppying it
up
um
[Music]
romo robe has weird mics
uh
hell is hamilton i don't know who she is
skyler sisters are hot that's the race
of this girl's apartment staying and
she's white
uh
i think i don't know what sorts of
things are generally taboo in korean
comedy scene whether or not you agree
with them insulting the great dear
supreme leader kim jong-un
kim song
salute
to
the man that kept north korea hermit
kingdom
uh generally taboo is uh being
anti-south korean jay park or che bom
j bom
uh someone he was like in uh
2 p.m or 2 a.m or some korean band and
someone was digging through his tweets
when he was like in the korean
boot camp for a k-pop
and they found a tweet where he's like
man i hate south korea they don't even
have [ __ ] frito-lays or some [ __ ]
they're like look he hates south korea
he's not one of us and then there was
like a huge mob and then he got
cancelled in korea
and um so they uh they treasure loyalty
and uh
koreanness it's it's a whole different
country over there i don't know if
you've ever been to korea but it's not
america it's
like a land it's like their home it's
korea it's it's where they all are it's
like
it's like it is their home that's where
they they're from it's the land and you
know it's like
it's it's cool you see a building it's
like the science building this is where
the koreans do science in here um and
this is the [ __ ] you know business
building they they just build buildings
and it's like controlled by koreans and
it's just
it's um
it's like going to an alien planet and
then being like oh so this is where you
guys live as you built it all for you to
live here
and all that
nice soy boy neck brace yeah i got it
because i was choking [ __ ] out
with [ __ ]
[ __ ] um
triangles i guess
did kim jong-il really invent the
burrito
if he did that'd be ill
um
have you seen the propaganda game
documentary no i haven't i love
propaganda i love the idea of it
our minds are moldable and shapeable
atheists be like everything i own was
designed and created but there's no way
that all of nature was created
no way lol well if there's data that
nature was created i mean nature is
created i create nature in the toilet
every day so i don't know what you mean
by created
um
but everything i designed and owned just
because uh this table was designed by
someone doesn't mean that a god exists
um
i mean uh there is a creator it's stars
stars exploding created all the atoms
um i don't know
like if that's how you prove that god
exists is just because things
are created i don't know i think i need
more more proof than that
um can you roast yourself yeah i have a
long face
i have small eyes i cut my own hair
i uh
whatever
uh
you're supposed to do that once in
middle school and never again not at 35.
your eyes
um i'm very skinny uh still making any
trips to san antonio yeah i'm working on
it on a show
in san antonio hopefully william go will
go with me
he hasn't confirmed yet but i am
planning to go to
the blind tiger so stay tuned on my ig
i'm in dallas next friday two shows
at the dallas comedy club so if you're
in dallas come out and in houston
tomorrow thursday
yeah
cut this [ __ ]
that way i don't have to go talk to some
woman who doesn't like talking to
autistic people and think she's better
than nerds
uh
and pretend to like
commune with her and whatever
uh you know i just cut my own hair i
don't have to spend 25 bucks on a
cheerleader
uh
i don't know yeah i don't mean to sound
like women hating but
most of them are women and like super
cuts and all that and it's just like
some of them are cool people
but i don't i don't enjoy being forced
to talk to people
and uh in hair cuttery situations it's
like
uh i don't know i don't like it i'd
rather just
be here just learn how to listen to hans
yeah
women
why don't you all change for me
a tornado going through a junkyard can
make a functional commercial airplane
hey hans animals plants beautiful
landscapes are way more impressive than
your stupid table lol
so you don't think that animals evolve
from lower animals organisms
i just don't understand why
in 2022 we're having this conversation
um
i uh so
uh
so you think that like um
because animals are so complicated
someone must have made it but
there must be a complicated animal that
can be made not by a creator but by
slowly evolving over time given enough
time
so i mean just because it's complicated
doesn't mean that someone had to have
created it it could have just been
natural selection
and i mean even if you don't think that
uh
you know like maybe god was in charge of
natural selection just put your god into
a corner more and more as we learn more
he's like in charge of natural selection
uh because it's pretty obvious that if
you have a cell
that divides and it keeps dividing it's
going to get better and better and then
it's going to give
way to lots of different [ __ ]
animals are complicated but
you know there's lots of ways to create
complicated things from simplicity
and we have enough time and resources on
hand to make that happen
um
i mean barbershops are great but it's
money
and uh
you don't have to talk
uh you were whining yesterday and it
sounds like you got this whole lineup
coming up i fell for it oh i'm sorry if
i made everyone sad by being sad but uh
i
i hope i can convey my emotions
accurately
and maybe i fall through pits of
depression and it's not pleasant to
watch but hey at least there's an upside
to it so keep watching if you're sad now
uh hopefully it'll get better
i like the boobs on my shoulder during
the haircut yeah that's pretty nice
um you know i wonder how conscious it is
some people do it more than others um
but uh yeah i mean i don't really uh
i don't really know if i should go
expect that because then if you're
expecting it then you're weird then
you're
you're all in the chair like oh this is
just how i sit yeah you're just gonna
have to cut around it i guess
my telegrams are right here
always got my telegrams ready
um abiogenesis and radical mu tint
speciation are far-fetched
when you said you're an atheist because
you go on internet pretty much made me a
fan thank you
i don't think the other guy's a fan
where's the salt lick i don't know
i don't know where the salt lick is
um but yeah i mean there's a reason
deer lick salt licks and uh
what you think you're better than a deer
um
i trust in the wisdom of the deer
so i also lick salt licks
uh talk about physics and gravity i love
physics uh you know
statics dynamics
pulleys weights mass times gravity
uh is the force uh exerted downward
uh on earth and uh you know it's all
about
uh allaying that force in different
directions
you pull up on a lever with mass times
gravity then uh you lift it
uh you know one half mv squared of mass
times velocity squared divided by two
is like the energy or something the
force
it's just all math you know like
you push
you push this laptop
it's the force pushing back on it the
spring and the whatever spring in the
laptop
uh you know with the spring constant and
it's just cool that uh everything that
we see
can be quantified in numbers
and it's just cool that uh we live in a
universe that can be described and
understood and i think that my time in
uh
uh
my time in learning all this [ __ ] in
georgia tech for my mechanical
engineering degree really gave me a
sense of the world
and taught me like how to look at things
as forces and
clamping and friction and
sheer
stress and all that
really let me know about different
things
would you rock the colorful kpop bowl
cut yes so stop being so true to your
cell phones
he did open for joe yesterday
sorry if you were depressed for me i
forget that sometimes my depression is
spreadable i'll try to keep my mask on
my metaphorical mask to keep my
depression
uh follicles inside my
brain mouth does god live at the bottom
of the ocean
um
sure
the v is always a bit uncomfortable
that's where my shoulder titties
he's a voice
soul and left nodes in the neck it's
just a disc problem
do you have a particular platform you
want us to check out
no not really i can put everything on my
youtube and you're already on my youtube
um
i would like to diversify my
portfolio and i'm
broadcasting on twitch as well
uh
william's show next week
are you talking about the creek william
wasn't able to do the show at the creek
um
yeah i mean
let's take it off
we're going
naked neck
this neck needs to be shown off to all
the world
[Music]
i um
i think it's funny that
from
i'm not high i'm not tired my eyes are
open
um
yeah like i wish i was high i guess
being high is fun but it [ __ ] up my
throat so
the thing is like whenever i go to the
joe rogan shows or the kill tony's it's
just so terrible how much free weed is
available
and uh then i usually smoke some of it
um
i am asian um i think asians are the
next superpower since america is making
every mistake in the book
um
i think that
we have a more stable solution and i
think that maybe we need to do a better
job with emphasizing the power of the
individual
and
really letting people be creative and be
crazy and
weird
and i think the best balance would be
both but of course i would say that i'm
korean american i want to
um
i go i want to you know
figure it i want to
create a world where i have the most
advantages so i want to create a world
where america and asia can survive as
one i am the lube that will make
america's [ __ ] slide gently into asia's
anus
um
and i hope that we can
do a lot of thrusts back and forth
um
i uh
you're getting less funny
hans you have one job [ __ ] do it bud
what the [ __ ] is your job
your job your name is a joke my [ __ ]
um but yeah i mean
all these people think that uh they need
to bully me and
reprimand me and you know do all these
boomer spanking type child raising
techniques
but actually that's not a helpful way to
develop and grow
it's
what you had to go through
and what uh
made you the bitter angry person that
you are and i hope to never become like
that
but thank you for telling me that i'm
bad at what i do i'm sorry that you feel
that that's an okay thing to say to
people because then you probably say it
to yourself
but um
i mean
i think that it's better to be nice and
nurturing and help people grow with love
and kindness than uh
berating them and telling them that
they're bad at the one thing that
they're trying to do and
just tearing them down
um but yeah
i appreciate that
you're trying to make me a better person
i guess
i just wish that you're more competent
and able to do it
encourage people in a way that doesn't
make you look so
repugnant
uh
i do say it myself that's what makes me
a better guy
uh yeah i mean
that's great i'm glad that you're
berating yourself
maybe try being nicer to yourself i
think that you're a beautiful person my
[ __ ]
and uh you're probably very wet and very
got a lot of flaps on you my [ __ ] and i
bet you got a nice juicy little [ __ ]
so you know
look at the good side don't just look at
your yeast infections
mike [ __ ]
um
do you know about mud flawed and tartary
no i guess i don't know a lot of things
a lot of things any strawberry but i
shredded cake
uh
um so i uh
i wrote a lot of stuff today um
i think that mma is a beautiful sport
i think that
things
can be better if we recognize that we
are a collective consciousness and make
the behavior of our collective
uh
consciousness better and not just let it
fall to the wayside and do whatever
uh
the people
that control our subconscious want to do
um
uh you know
okay
uh joining unions start worshiping
billionaires they're not better than us
we should be making our own decisions
you have to worship billionaires to let
them do what they're doing
um that came after i sang the solidarity
forever song at a karaoke and they cut
me off early and i was like join a union
um
you know
don't let don't worship billionaires
they're not better than us we should be
making our own decisions
um i just think that
we let billionaires design our cities
and that's why we have giant highways
running through our city centers and
we have
an unwalkable communities that are not
fit for humans i mean if you go outside
into one of these strip mall
like [ __ ]
strodes
these giant
six-lane highways
uh
that you're supposed to drive like 45
miles per hour through it's not for
humans which is ridiculous because we
are humans and we design cities
that we can't exist in comfortably it's
not comfortable to walk through a road
that has cars traveling at 50 miles per
hour zooming past your head
and kicking up all that pollution and
brake dust
um so
yeah why don't we design our cities for
ourselves for human beings instead of
cars which we get in occasionally but we
aren't
uh cars if cars were an alien species
and i came down to earth it'd be like
thank you for building us this wonderful
environment even though it is to your
detriment
fight club
yeah i mean we have power we are the
people we should do whatever we want
instead of letting a billionaire tell us
what to do because the billionaire is
only going to make decisions that
benefit a billionaire we are going to
make decisions that benefit us and if we
can control
things
then we can make a better world for us
and not just five billionaires
how do you feel about electric vehicles
i mean a lot of pollution is created by
brake dust and
tires
or whatever
i think that electric cars are great but
i think even greater than electric cars
is walking walking is really good for
you it releases uh your blood and it's
like how your body is meant to function
like if you walk around then your body
like kicks into gear all this [ __ ]
that's tied into walking like your
immune system and your [ __ ]
circulatory system but
if you just sit in your car all day then
your body doesn't have that energy
that you get from walking
to convert into a blood pump pumping
this and then your body just has to
force blood
uh without that [ __ ]
blood for without that walking energy
like uh you create a lot of energy when
you're walking you're jostling around
you're going back and forth and that
does [ __ ] to your [ __ ]
i think public transportation is amazing
i think it's more efficient if you look
at how many cars it takes to transport
seven
d people 70 people in cars it's like it
goes all the way back here but 70 people
in a train
it's like very much smaller and it's
just a better way instead of making our
cities for cars we should make them for
people
uh but then if you don't have cars you
can't jet out of downtown and go to your
suburb and escape the horrible community
of people that you made because you
wanted to import slaves and use them as
free labor and live like a [ __ ]
spartan in the 1800s
so whatever
i used to live in glasgow
the city council there openly said that
the cars give them more from texas so
they won't build bicycle lanes
um yeah i mean if the people control the
uh government then it's like whatever
hans used to walk around seattle like a
bum i drove around seattle like a rich
suburban child
trains are very bad for pandemics
um but luckily
we can shelter in place we live in an
amazon era
but unfortunately we won't do it
um
party time
would you ever consider skydiving while
doing stand-up fly down comedy
uh sure
i don't really want to
you know
if i'm doing fly down comedy i would
just like talk to people like i'm flying
down i think if you do stand-up comedy
just like hi guys oh i'm on johnny
carson right now and you're in like a
shitty art dive bar then you're not
going to be in the moment so i tried to
do comedy in a way that uh it's uh
honest to where i am so i would do
comedy
skydiving in a way that's honest to
where i am and flying and all that
uh
how do you generally unique crazy things
that happen in your life to comedy
that's what i can't figure out
very dark comedy is where my mind seems
to go
um
how do you turn the unique crazy thing
doesn't matter about it i mean um you
shouldn't uh you should just express
yourself
and get it out there even if it seems
dark to you um there's a way to turn
that not dark and the way that you turn
it not dark is by [ __ ] up and turning
it dark and then you realize oh [ __ ]
that's not socially uh viable
uh and then you just keep practicing and
doing it over and over again until you
figure it out and then
you know like i can't tell you how to do
you you know you're very unique and
apparently you're very dark
and you need to express that because if
you're dark then we need to know that
you're dark so that we know
uh what all the diodes on the board are
saying and uh if you're going through
some dark [ __ ] you should let people
know so that we know that you're going
through some dark [ __ ] and then we have
a more accurate representation of the
world
um and that uh you're suffering and that
there's suffering going on and then we
don't act oblivious
but we internalize and recognize the
suffering that you're going through and
maybe work as a society to eliminate as
much suffering on a large scale as
possible by giving people basic human
rights
asians won't research the great tartarus
can i mention i'm glad
sucking on himalayan salt today
don't dent me
uh i would love
i'm sorry i was slurping my drink
you can come over to my house if you
ever go to vancouver
okay thanks man i love vancouver
vancouver is a very walkable city
somewhat
um i didn't make any resolutions um
joe rogan price of this on his podcast
but he also said it
yesterday in the green room which i was
invited to because i was booked at 8 10
p.m
um but he was like
this girl this girl is so annoying in
the green room
uh she's like actually that's just the
way that the way that things go is like
it's just you just need to have like a
two-year plan
and it was like she was just like really
like uh if you know she was just saying
everything she was thinking and like it
didn't actually work grammatically but
she would just say anything
and she was in the green room talking to
joe rogan and she's like so what's your
like two year plan what's your plan for
the future like do you have a two year
plan and like how did what are you gonna
do in two years and joe's like i don't
i've never done that i've never had a
two-year plan i just do whatever i like
to do and i do it consistently and have
discipline about it but uh yeah i don't
i don't
write down oh this is what i want to do
it's like he said that it's a lot of
procrastination
um
that
they just don't want to actually work
towards their goal they just want to
imagine having it instead of actually
doing it because doing it is hard and
boring but thinking about having it
that's fun and if you can make imagining
being successful
into uh
and
trick yourself into thinking that you're
working hard towards your goal then uh
it's a it's a circular loop you're just
going to be imagining how awesome your
life's going to be and then it's never
going to happen
i know a lot of mma fighters they
visualize their victory and visualize
doing the victor victorious finishing
blow
and that helps him
uh actually do that but that's like the
icing on the cake
the
chunky
chunky bready part of the cake is the
hard work and the hours of practicing
kicks
and uh punching and
you know
doing all that good [ __ ] that actually
makes that visualization possible
so you know maybe if i
um you know do that maybe i'll be a
better person
maybe if i have enough whatever
uh where do you get your ideas from uh
from observing the society around me and
living my life and being a human being
all the best parts of whatever my comedy
is is
the best parts of all people i respect
people and i love people and so i love
myself because i'm a person
and
i think that
i think that if you don't love people
then you think that you have to be
something that you're not but you are a
person and you gotta love people because
you are a person and you're surrounded
by people and there's a lot of good
things about people and uh that's inside
you
or whatever
um but yeah i uh i love humanity and i
try to uh
find the common
themes in all our lives because that is
probably universal and probably helps me
the most instead of finding like a
specific thing about me like the unique
way that
you know i
grow my eyebrow hair or something
my favorite mitch head brick joke is
probably
i used to do drugs i still do but i used
to too
i think it's just great how simple it is
and how it plays with the language
bro you [ __ ] up question mark question
mark question mark
nope completely sober i took a nap doing
pretty good
how did you get into podcasting what's
your three year plan
oh my god with the three year plan i
just did a thing about two-year plans
and then you did a three-year plan on me
how did i get into podcasting um i was
like i do comedy that only takes up
three minutes at a time for open mics
and [ __ ]
tony does know i'm a bleeding heart
liberal um
and then i was like well what else can i
do i could just talk endlessly for hours
so then i was like uh what's the lowest
effort art form i can do podcasting so i
decided to get into podcasting because
it's so easy
do you know any korean proverbs
it's this thing i heard on a korean
drama
it means you gave me the disease and
then you gave me the medicine
it's like when you're like dude you're
so [ __ ] fat dude i bet it takes
forever to find your little dick instead
of all your fat
and then
and your friend is hurt you're like dude
i was just kidding you're so [ __ ]
awesome dude the fact that you're so fat
makes you like really physically
intimidating and
and uh
i think that
you should be my you should you should
go talk to that chick because chicks
love big strong men
then he'd be like you gave me the
disease now you give me the medicine why
don't you just not give me the disease
to begin with and then you don't have to
do all that
um so you guys want to hear some
royalty-free music
while i go take a [ __ ]
um
because i gotta take a [ __ ]
uh
maybe what's the thing about [ __ ]
playing other people's youtube videos
miami vice
it's 50 minutes hopefully i'll take less
time to [ __ ] in 50 minutes
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
um
maybe
poop outside
and he's locked out i just took a [ __ ] i
don't know how long that was that was
pretty short in terms of the shits that
i take i like to sit on the toilet and
really make sure everything's out
i haven't had a job in a while so i
haven't really had to make sure my shits
are on like a short time scale
i mean maybe if i did have a job i'd
make sure my shits were even longer but
yeah
i usually like to sit there and just let
my [ __ ] just dangle over the water
and make sure everything uh
all this [ __ ] from the [ __ ] just
falls out just to make sure nothing is
in there
um
but yeah it's good to be in a in a house
the biggest thing about van life is the
shits
are very hard to do
um if uh it's in the daytime i usually
go to like a starbucks
or like
a target
if it's at night time then i either
[ __ ] at a comedy club or
i uh
my [ __ ] in my trash can and then bag it
up and throw it away
or i [ __ ] outside
[Music]
which is what i did when i was camping
so
i used to camp out in the desert for two
weeks at a time and then i'd go back
into the city for more videos
but
i really miss those times being out in
nature
being away from everyone and just being
by myself and just complete silence and
aloneness
it was an amazing feeling i mean you're
never really alone like in california
there were like jets flying all over the
place just training and practicing
um and there's like other people who are
camping
camping they have like these huge setups
and they all gather together in these
giant [ __ ]
caravan villages and then they ride atvs
all over the place kicking up dust i'd
be away from them and be in like a
little corner mount superstition is what
i'm thinking of and as long as you're
not in an acc
area of concern of environmental concern
or something
you can be out there
and everyone would be together in the
same place and i'd be like far away all
alone
oh man
i miss that i miss being in the desert
but i like being in society and
civilization and being able to do cool
shows like joe rogan shows
so it's like you know
i use society for to make my life better
because without society my life is
meaningless my the whole point of my
life is to
improve society and other people and
make other people's lives better
um otherwise i have no purpose or point
so just being out in the woods just
feeling comfortable and pleasurable and
peaceful is nice but it's a shallow goal
and i need some i need some bigger
purpose in my life
and that is to help the society and
tribe that i was born and i am a part of
and my society and tribe unfortunately
unfortunately is one of the best biggest
most technologically advanced tribes in
the world and in the universe
and in history and in the galaxy
so
i am obligated by my tribe to make an
impact on a galactic and uh
you know very large scale so if i want
to be a part of this society i have to
go for something grand and large and
that's why i pick comedy because comedy
is uh
thinking and thoughts and just
transmitting my ideas and thoughts to
the world i think is a very cool
thing to do
so yeah i mean unfortunately
we have to make such a big contribution
on a large scale but fortunately we have
the tools of technology and the minds
that our
ancestral
hominids have gifted us to be able to do
that i'm not just like a
crow magnum or an austral
australopithecus trying to
um you know formulate
ideas and thoughts about what i think
everyone else should hear
um
how old are
question mark how old are
question mark german moreno forgot the
uh subject or object
remember on kill tony said a girl finger
your butthole are you okay
yeah i mean it was a weird experience
and i'm glad that i went through it uh
but yeah i'm okay
it's not like a terrible thing it's just
normal it's 20 22 now
um
should i go to the yellow rows of the
red rose hans i can only make it to one
of them i am personally i have an
affinity for stormy
uh so i would go to the yellow rose but
i heard the red rose is good too
but uh yeah stormy is that the yellow
rose
and uh i would love to go visit stormy
and see what she's all about
um very skinny boy
and
[Music]
i
can't always handle the rigors of a lap
dance sometimes they gyrate on me too
hard and i uh
they're used to big beefy men apparently
because they rock my world literally
maybe just do a little light uh penis
rubbing or something but everyone has a
different style and you just gotta find
a style that fits you
yellow rose is where it's at
i thought you're asking where yellow
rose is
and i was just gonna say google it
because i can't provide a very good
answer just verbally like
it's on the latitude of 94.179
and the other one how old are you i got
it this time
uh i'm
32. um i'm pretty old i'm an old old man
um but i have the i'm a late bloomer so
it's uh it makes sense you know i didn't
get laid for a while and then
i still have the skin of uh
when i'm supposed to get laid so it's
like i still have time
i can still go to a college and not
appear as creepy as
my 32 year old brethren
um
because i look like a little boy so i
can prey upon
young children
but unfortunately i'm still awkward as
[ __ ] and i refuse to give it up
anyone can get laid by being confident
it takes a real
real man to get laid with no confidence
that's true skill
oh you just become a better person and
you get laid anyone can be a better
person and get laid i'm trying to get
laid by not changing myself at all just
kidding i did a lot of work to change
myself and honestly it's quite
exhausting
and i don't know how much longer i can
keep it up so i hope that i become
[ __ ] soon because i'm running out of
energy
uh favorite member of sistar
uh
i don't really know them that well but i
love their songs very very poppy but
they just lean into the poppiness
they're like we're just going to create
just
the shallowest songs ever but make it
awesome so that it's not shallow anymore
uh cute matthew that's what thought
i have no idea what the [ __ ] that meant
hadpad
who matthew that's what thought
um
yeah i mean i love
women
i love people i love some men
uh not in a sexual way i love a lot of
women in a sexual way but um i love
interacting with people and getting to
know them and you know i just don't want
to go outside my wheelhouse and try to
get chicks that don't know me because
i think that
you know especially in america i think
people are very offended if you want to
sexually uh have congress with them
they're like i need this to survive
don't just ruin it to have fun
i need health care and all that so i
think it's like a more vicious
environment
out there and they get offended if you
want to [ __ ] them it's like oh sorry
um but i think that it where people like
know me and where i have an advantage
uh i feel like i get treated like i
think i should
where how i'm entitled to get treated
um
but yeah i mean i just i don't
want to need fame to
or
you know
kill tony people to [ __ ] me but it's
like if i don't have that
it's brutal
girls are so mean
uh they think they deserve to be mean to
you because
you're trying to [ __ ] them and that's
that's a bad thing you should be trying
to [ __ ] people
you just
think that they're attractive from afar
or something
did you hear what happened yesterday
yeah a lot of things happened yesterday
entitled the american way yeah it's
manifest destiny i can manifest my
destiny of uh
you know it's like uh i don't want to
look at [ __ ] as an object but uh
if
if i don't have it a lot then it's like
[ __ ]
uh
the only only way
to think about it is like an object
because it's like it's definitely if i
take it like a personal thing then it's
like oh i'm just personally a shitty
person or something which i probably am
but uh
i don't know how shitty am i am i this
shitty i don't think so
but yeah i'm uh in cell
i um
i'm bitter i guess but i'm working on it
i think women are great or whatever they
make all the right decisions all the
time
um
just a horn dog hans work on your game
and you'll be good
i detest
working on my game
i uh i probably will
do the least amount of effort possible
and
try to
try hard in whatever way that i do it
i do lots of psychedelics
i think it's
tough to be a woman and i think we
should give them basic human rights and
then
then also stop raping them because
that's a pretty terrible thing that men
do to women
um
and i think men are very much shittier
than women i think that
we
are brainwashed by capitalist propaganda
more than women are and they have more
uh niceness and intuition about how to
be decent people and they don't just
take jobs to make more money
they uh take jobs to live good lives and
be fulfilled and be happy and make a
positive impact in the world
so i think that's
where it should be at
yeah i mean uh
discrimination women treating men shitty
is bad but
men treating ugly women shitty is like
way worse uh hans are you a liberal i'm
guessing under your definition of
liberal that i am
um but liberal has so many different
definitions but yes i'm on the left side
of the political spectrum and i think
that's the correct side that's the side
that wasn't enslaving people and
dragging gay people through the dirt
roads and
making marijuana illegal and
invading foreign countries for bananas
and uh
i just think they were more correct
overall and it's the future and they're
technologically more advanced my date
just f me out of our date because she
caught code that's a good thing you
don't want to get code your date did you
a favor if only we could all be so kind
we need them they don't need us i don't
know i thought that's about are you
really autistic i mean you be the judge
it's not like a [ __ ] solid thing it's
like
such a
amorphous disease and people just say
that offhandedly but yeah i mean you
need a doctor to tell you what i'm like
you know what i'm like i'm telling you
what i'm like
democrats wanted slavery but that's the
dixiecrats they're on the right side of
the political spectrum the party
switched
look it up
um
yeah i mean uh the people in the south
wanted slavery and they were democrats
in the past but now the republicans the
name changed their ideology didn't it
doesn't really matter what they
call themselves they're on the right
side of the political spectrum of
wanting to
preserve the old way of doing things
and enslaving people
um
associating with either side a massive
indicator that someone is a little
brainwashed um i mean you have to
associate with something you can't just
be apathetic
and uh
lazy all your life at some point you're
gonna [ __ ] figure out what you
believe in and what you think is going
on
uh that moves with everything there
should be an autism meter in the bottom
left-hand corner that moves with every
statement
um yeah i mean uh
why is uh being an animal and just
talking emotionally the most treasured
thing and talking logically and with a
lot of thought and
logic and conscious effort supposed to
be a disease i think that the way that
people talk animalistically is a disease
and how they only think about their
feelings and emotion and don't have any
logical
through through
thorough
through through lying through their
through their conversation is a kind of
a dumb way to talk and it's actually
worse than being autistic so
uh these jocks
and these um you know these
uh shopaholics think that uh not being
able to talk to them is a disease but uh
i don't wanna talk you can't talk to me
like i can talk to jocks and idiots
and uh athletes and like people who
always want to be cool but like people
who are like
cool and always awesome all the time
they cannot talk to nerds because they
need to feel cool all the time and if
they feel a little bit of awkwardness or
a little uncool then they're like
freaking out
um
yeah i mean you should learn how to talk
to nerds nerds uh can talk to you you
can't talk to nerds because you need to
be cool all the time
um but yeah i mean i think it's cool to
be different types of people i just
think that there's more discrimination
going from
jocks hating nerds than nerds hating
jocks
i think that
i would love to talk to jocks but
they don't want to learn a new way of
talking nerds have to constantly learn
new ways of talking and recognize that
their way of being is uh
unnatural and unsustainable but jocks
never have to do that so they just keep
getting worse and worse
uh from personal pain not just because
you picked a side to stand for something
uh yeah i mean you should mold your
views from personal opinion
but then you realize that one side is
consistently illogical and always
pursuing their self-interest and
short-term profits and the other side is
more logical and pursuing the best for
all people and that side is the left
side and the side that's more interested
in preserving an unequal wealth
distribution is the right side of this
political spectrum
um but uh
oh it says opening for work and pay i'm
not telling you i don't want to
piss off anyone
including the people that book me so
yeah i mean
i i'll tell you if i'm given permission
to
um
are you still talking about slavery what
the [ __ ] it's 2022 slavery is over
there's more black ceos in the world
more than ever yeah but there's way more
white ceos and slavery is over but
we still have confederate flag statues
and
a lot of
remnants of the slavery time still
existing in our current world we haven't
totally
repented and reformed our ways from our
slavery past like the nazis or the
germans did after nazi germany we kind
of loved it we were like no i'm not
gonna apologize for that i'm gonna keep
on living the way that i'm living
uh have you put enough time into
developing your opinion on this hands
bro
on these hands
bro you can't even threaten me properly
have you put enough time into developing
your opinion on this hands this hand bro
well you're going to jerk me off
uh you want to pluralize
uh
these
this these
um but yeah i mean uh if you want to
jerk me off whatever republicans ended
slavery in america and the right wing
started slavery in america
the conservatives started slavery in
america
is jorgen going to take you on the road
i hope so i'm uh
obviously very very eager and happy to
do that but uh
you know who am i to demand it you say
with the same cringey smugness most
people left off holy [ __ ] don't meet
your heroes folks
i'm pretty far on the left
um yeah i mean it's hard to not be smug
when uh your opponents have been wrong
about slavery and gay marriage and
marijuana it's like why are we even
listening to these people
just because they exist doesn't mean
that they are um
they have a point or that you should put
a space in your mind for them logically
i still want to be nice to them i still
want to be kind but
yeah i'm not debating this anymore this
is already gay people deserve rights
they're not horrible people uh so you
should enslave people you should give
people a nice society to live in and if
they don't do well then uh
then uh it's not their fault if you put
them in a horrible situation
um but yeah i mean i don't want to be
smug but
i think believing in some of the things
that right-wing people believe is
horrific and
it's hard for me to stomach that
emotionally so i
guess i am smugged as a defense
mechanism so that
i can continue progressing my thought
past do black people deserve human
rights
um
but uh yeah i mean i i love the right
wing i love you know a cold beer on a
summer night i love a pickup truck i
just don't love their idea for how to
treat minorities or wealth distribution
you can't just say something good claim
and claim it's left many people on the
right would agree with your statements
that's true i shouldn't uh make it so
polarizing so that you have to give up
everything that you held there to agree
with me
um you know there's a lot of things that
we don't have to label left or right
that are good
like the left
and right is a very binary way to see
the world and it's also a product of the
american culture that i grew up in is
like heaven and hell
angel and demon
uh left and right uh but it should be
like more
more uh
whatever more in line
uh oh so your own opinions suck because
there are people on the right that
literally would agree
i agree uh maybe i should uh should be
more
nice to whatever
the conservatives but uh yeah i mean i
like to
progress past abortion
i think abortion is you should be able
to kill babies babies need to be
murdered
uh jesus was a socialist have you kicked
it with tim dillon i saw tim dillon
yesterday dude's [ __ ] hilarious he
[ __ ] murdered last night
uh
and uh he's very very politically minded
go shooting when you're camping is legal
out there i would love to go shooting i
haven't had a gun when i've been camping
i watch i wish i was out there right now
they're from jail said gill so you can
check out the wacky wisdom podcast
um i do love uh all sorts of people i
think that uh
um i think that in korea the right wing
is also been tainted by the uh american
politics and all that but i think that
with uh in korea there's like a more
fundamentally
uh sound like uh cultural backdrop to
the conservatives
i'm sure that conservatives are horrible
in korea too but uh it's like tradition
and the old way of thinking and like
camping and hunting and like
uh
you know all that [ __ ] isn't tainted
with like you know the same [ __ ] that it
is in america so like i hold i hold a
lot of beliefs that uh some people might
think are right
um
feytus tells her selling about her about
the present for elementary i'll start
the biggest [ __ ] ever
that was just some asian guy sir oreos
uh what happened to paige did she still
go to kill tony shows no she doesn't
um she
broke up with me multiple times
and uh you know i don't think she really
wanted to be with me she thought she
could do better and i hope she is
hey girl i want to really think so nasty
germany was national socialist
democratic people's republic of korea is
uh democratic
um
[Music]
yeah i mean um
what else is going on i
don't want to piss anyone off
[Music]
let's see people are just no evolved i'm
at a hotel bar watching this hi hans oh
my god at a hotel bar i can't even
imagine being at a hotel bar right now
that's such a mind [ __ ] because it's
such a different environment
um
where's christy i believe that you meant
to spell that with a k
and a y at the end christie vera she is
in um
chrissy vera's uh in atlanta she posted
it on her instagram so i don't feel bad
telling you all
but uh yeah she is a [ __ ]
uh
in atlanta right now she's making her
way on over here she's gonna be here
soon apparently
and i hope that she's having a good time
on her way over here and i hope that uh
she will actually have sex with me one
of these days but that's not necessary
uh it's just something that i really
really want and uh
think about sometimes
but uh yeah i mean she's a great person
to hang out with who i also want to have
sex with like uh i hope that's okay to
say because
whatever but uh she is a little uh wild
and
um
she's uh
she's a little uh
she she just does whatever she wants and
sometimes it's not always uh
it's not always uh
something that she should do in polite
society but she's i think she's a nice
person at heart and she's very smart and
very interesting and i enjoy hanging out
with her because she just does whatever
she wants
um
i finally left my mom's basement
congrats mood at verma
mudd it
i did a podcast with him very early on
in the pandemic whoever thinks their
political ideas don't have a
totalitarian extreme to them as clueless
yeah i mean uh we shouldn't uh murder
people and put them in camps but uh to
not
uh have confidence in your political
opinions is weak and you should believe
in what you believe in
and
stand by the conviction of your thoughts
because those are the only people who
change the world
what's your favorite check you've kissed
on kill tony stormy was very good um and
she's just my type she's like a girl
that i would fantasize over so it's
amazing that i get to kiss her do you
believe you have a sex addiction um i
mean if i haven't had sex in three
months
i don't think i have a sex edition
i think i want a sex edition i think i'm
addicted to wanting to be addicted to
sex
do you think jk rowling jr still arrive
live and will run for president
jkr jr i think he meant jfk
jr is still live
jkr jr
um love other people says victor vitor
spencer thank you
uh i will sell merch soon i had
something sent in but
i got lost in the mail so i'm waiting
for that to develop
hopefully it'll be at the vulcan
entitlement much yeah i think i'm
entitled to [ __ ] just like a starving
person is entitled to food
um but yeah i mean i don't think that uh
women should give me sex i think that uh
we should be having a lot more sex as a
generation and then i'm a part of this
generation so i also want to have more
sex but
uh is it normal to not want sex
should that be the norm where we're like
ew gross people are gross i don't have
sex with any of them i think that's
that's a bad way to do it
political opinions are gay
no one should have thoughts on politics
because
that makes you so lame dude
that would be interesting to see which
countries do it for covert which side of
the political spectrum they are on
yeah i mean covet is a crazy crazy
pandemic
uh when the hell are you gonna go to the
jre
probably
14 months from now
if i'm lucky that's the fast track
[Music]
maybe in 2022
but you know
it's not like i'm entitled to it it's
not like vagina which i am no i'm just
kidding
uh yeah i mean it's like
it's like a woman uh you don't want to
be like i deserve your [ __ ] i need your
[ __ ]
uh i shouldn't go up to joe and be like
hey joe i need to get on jre it's my
destiny we were meant to be
you know i just gotta let go with the
flow man just chill out just hang out
and soon maybe it'll happen
what are your thoughts on the large pc
movement within the left um i think that
they are
products of american culture and they
approach
being on the left
side of the spectrum
uh with the same zeal that a
conservative approaches their
conservatism
and they're just like it's a game to
them it's they want to win and how can
you blame them they learn from their
fathers
so i mean
you
enslave people you
invade foreign countries you make banana
republics in latin america you
uh have uh oppressive uh labor rights
and this is what you get you get
annoying lefties and i think that's a
just punishment
uh from now on all your thanksgivings
will be ruined because you ruined
costa rica and nicaragua
but also the pc movement is
authoritarian and gay
as according to jasmine
is your favorite comedian probably dr
flabadus
uh what's easier jerry your [ __ ]
i mean joe rogan had like
what's like 2 000
guests on um
so i would say
there's 2 000 people that have been on
jerry or something
and there are
billions of people who have had sex so i
would say jerry is more precious than
sex i think a lot of people would give
up sex for five years to be on jre
although it shouldn't be a choice
um
do i listen to any comedy pods yeah i
love comedy pods i love pods like
uh joe rogan i love pods like come town
i used to love a lot of different pods
but i gotta go shave joe rogan's show
starts at eight uh thank you guys for
being here
and i love it i love everything
how does it feel living right free and
living off of your friends it feels
amazing because i'm not really hurting
her
uh and uh it's a it's it was gonna be
here anyway so i don't really feel bad
about it and i think it's a great uh
place to be
um
so thank you guys so much and i love you
and i hope to play katan tonight who
knows i never know what's happening